welcome to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by listen before I even go into this
it's August 27 [ __ ] I think in a
week and a half it's the NFL time it's
time to make some [ __ ] Jesus and I
know that you got a system or you have a
friend and this and this but by [ __ ]
October morning its ass busted you're
not gonna have a book I'm gonna offer
you a book today cuz ever since I
started the podcast people have been
asking me for advice [ __ ] terrible
what team to bet on but the truth is I
don't know what's going in I don't know
who's gonna win I don't know but I do
know one thing you gotta check out my
bookie remember if you're bettin it's
just important what you who you're
betting with that's why I always tell
people to bet with my bookie trust me
these are the best bet this season
they've been in business for years they
have great reviews online and their
mobile site is easy to use so do me a
favor go check out my book eat that
right now watch they'll match your
deposit dollar for dollar use promo code
Church to activate the office visit my
bookie online today
that's my bookie my B oh oh hey I get
the crayon my my bo o ki and don't
forget to use promo code Church like a
[ __ ] when you creating your
account to claim up to a thousand
dollars in free play it's easy go to my
bookie you play you pay you get
[ __ ] paid alright number two
you're starting to die at the holidays
next have to next week you can't dress
right no more and you look like a
[ __ ] mutt you want to change you want
to get healthy you got to go down on it
calm right now and check out the great
line of supplements and they provide for
you whether it's alpha brain whether
it's room tech sports room tech immune I
got on a plane I pop ten of those
[ __ ] zoomtext immune why there's
there's people from every country and I
see people with day and a half froze the
turbans and Chinese people with masks so
I got to do what I got to do cuz I got
mouths to feed so I go and shoot that
[ __ ] immune the [ __ ] conquer all
those baddest PD those Milo's shoot
export if you want endurance you get
those [ __ ] at the mushrooms and you eat
two of those pills and you'll be [ __ ]
jumping up and down for hours Lotus no
doubt at that time right now press in
charge
BAM and get 10% off but his
gets better delivered to your
[ __ ] house it ain't the [ __ ]
drug deal it's [ __ ] Federal Express I
got a package from on it
boom it's daddy's girl on the dock time
right now press in church and get 10%
off kick this [ __ ] mealy what's
up you bad [ __ ] uncle Joey here
for starters I want to thank you if he
came out to either a Huntsville Alabama
Thursday night or his auntie's in
Nashville you audiences were [ __ ]
sensational I'm gonna give a shout-out
to the staff my men in the kitchen the
bartender's all the sexy waitresses and
waiters I love you [ __ ] had a
great time there
and I'm coming back Nashville and I want
to thank Harley bees for sending this
[ __ ] chicken and Lee's chicken from
[ __ ] Milan the [ __ ] tremendous
black people with no gloves on giving
you fried chicken takes me back in this
family to my days in Harlem [ __ ] in the
early seventies anyway that's all over
exciting what a motivational Monday it's
all about dog day
you ain't [ __ ] I don't even need my anal
beads today why did you do it I got a
Monday that's like 20 to 6 in the
morning oh yeah I live to get up at 6:00
20 to sell coffee a few [ __ ] dirt
road get on that [ __ ] computer let
people know it's Monday you gotta go out
and choke that [ __ ] whatever
you want your money yeah cuz people walk
around a little [ __ ] that don't you
know this ain't a [ __ ] pinball game
this is life [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] be doing drugs if you read
opiates whatever you gotta get up on
Monday and hustle that's fast as long as
you make a deal with yourself with some
I work 40 but I'm 55 pills I'm good if I
can have their pills that'd be great
there's nothing else there's nothing
like waking up on a Monday there's
nothing going on but guess what yes true
there's nothing going on we're talking
about you saw the when it's gonna
document because I couldn't believe you
saw it I know what made you what made
you watch that
oh just randomly I first of all I love
documentaries but randomly that one was
on and I was like all I've been wanting
to see this because I've been seeing the
promo for it on Showtime
but I watched like the affair
what's the shows I went like shameless
I'm dying up here is done but like the
affair still going so I've been seeing
the kymaro Mike I love Lynyrd Skynyrd I
love learning and then it was all I was
like I caught it right at the beginning
I was so happy it was like one morning I
got up at 7 I must have been channeling
you I never get up that early and I've
watched it Monday mornings I believe
that whatever you do any other day of
the week Mondays today home for the
whole week that's why I'm so against
Sunday night show like for years I was
always against Sunday night shows on the
road I fought hard as a feature act not
to work them because I feel that Monday
is a day of the Spirit it's a day that
your home I think you like candles you
[ __ ] think of the people died how
their that around but you still still
are on Monday not someone I get up every
morning and think of somebody whose
death Rhaego what the [ __ ] what would he
give today to get up single vision young
family what would he give today like I'm
thinking like going to gym but not
really my right know what [ __ ] that you
need that [ __ ] was here he'd be
at the [ __ ] gym right now it bank out
because that's how he would change life
so I draw on that [ __ ] especially on
Mondays for the rest of the week that's
amazing but if when you watch that
documentary like I've been preaching
whether Skynyrd something about the
Oakland show when I want like I watch I
have the Atlantic City shows on tape I
watch tons of their performances on line
ok and when you watch the other one I
watched the Leonard Skynyrd live from
Oakland it first time I watched it
destroyed my insides shut it down and
think about what I was doing wrong with
my comedy this is maybe two or three or
four years ago well at first I
discovered that my kind of stone stupor
we just yeah whatever and I just took me
away and I played it again and I
couldn't believe it and I didn't say no
nobody for a long time and I was
starting jiu-jitsu and I was going
through this thing comparing jujitsu to
the
anything that's an art okay it's all
really the same yeah whether you paint
whether you got on the subway and draw
one hand you have to do them same like
those guys finally onto the subway and
they pay with one hand the train is
moving their skill to do yeah you know
but that just doesn't help happen
overnight you have to find it you have
to get the strength to pull yourself
because I can't even pull myself up
never mind go for two miles drawing all
right like I want to see mission
impossible
you know that's a mission right there
holding on to a rope the bomb was
supposed to go over 15 minutes two hours
i sat there before the bomb went off I
never want to kick myself more in the
head how long this 15 minutes take Tom
Cruise can make 15 minutes turn into a
bucket ow
I'm sitting there going Jesus Christ
deliver a rock slips then a flop and
then in the man then the glove falls off
it was craziness but fun but spoiler
alert mission impossible go [ __ ]
yourself that's it it's that simple if I
went usually god I want to sit equalizer
do and it wasn't one yeah I'm still in
love a man on fire man a fire I can't
take anything else he does equalizer the
first one I like but I just see him so
my related so much to man on fire yeah
dad it's too much it's like Charles
Bronson the mechanic well that's awesome
the mechanic I related to that dude okay
that's what I wanted to be my mother
died I did never saw that I was a kid
but I always remembered that how he
killed people for a living
that's an interesting [ __ ] concept he
killed people for a living he got their
dossier and medical records yeah and he
just shot people for a living I thought
about it again till you know ten years
later when my mother died the [ __ ] run
myself a sentence a hit man cuz I got
emotions you know right but then when I
watch death wish
okay you know like death wish well you
you think about death with healing that
huh
the rape scene in death wish oh yeah
like as a kid like that gave me PTSD
like that taught me what the sexual
harassment was godlike that's that for
as a kid ten years then when we came out
in 70
oh and you saw it when you were like
good night with you and forty seconds we
didn't check IDs sure if you can breathe
into a glass yeah yeah and in the Union
City cinema they let you in all those
movies I saw those movies and I went
left they're like what the [ __ ] Charles
Bronson that rape scene even today
bothers the [ __ ] out of me you know was
in that rape scene yeah go boom
Jeff yes my acting career see you lucky
then rape you here see that yeah well he
wasn't into me I'm sleeping with my
other scene his acting class was a suck
a dick class I was he was teaching women
how to act like him in Harvey I said
Harvey was doing Harvey's learn how to
suck a dick class him on the first floor
and there we go bloom on that and the
other guy the junkie from taxi oh he had
a [ __ ] acting school you're kidding
he was T he was at the end he did
anything I mean that's all they do every
time we do a scene he'd go why isn't
this rehearsed I'm like cuz you took her
to Hawaii
jerk off how am I supposed to rehearse
it when you took my scene partner away
like you they did it every time are you
alright Lee I'm just I can't imagine
I'm trying to imagine Harvey's dick
sucking class I'm gonna see you study
the scene study from Last Tango in Paris
and I'm gonna play Marlon Brando you're
gonna suck my dick alright and do they
like does that go cuz I've heard like a
couple years ago this is not sexual but
I heard a casting agent for a major show
was running a casting seminar that you
had to go do to get on the show so but
are people just like having sex with
acting coaches to try to get somewhere
or they just don't talk about anything
everybody's having sex everybody gets
somewhere somewhere yes you you want to
move up somehow whatever way you can
when I win what it's a story Mia no more
weird acting class I love that I loved
acting classes I don't know I used to go
to one a mountain no I Santa Monica we
used in a fountain we used and that
sound like a mama look at the a with the
other kids I would be the one go [ __ ]
yourself don't stand up there in the
street Brian Reid he's still there yes
yeah you don't make him strength on the
street no more yeah
they have to go outside to rehearse
their scene and then you come back in
and you do it that's a cold reading time
it was great I mean it was great and
everything but I'm not standing on the
street [ __ ] cars are doing 90 I'm out
here with some chicken talking to
yourself yeah you are [ __ ] that [ __ ]
birudo so that was your first one no no
Wes was the first with Jeff Goldblum and
right Robert Robert Carnegie what was
the one that you signed up for where you
couldn't audition DW Brown and Joe bear
Joe and Perry beat the [ __ ] okay but I
never listened they told you couldn't
take off the Rams were in the Super Bowl
I took off I don't listen to nothing
they say like that was there also a
front for cosmetology right Scientology
Joe and Baron did like Scientology yeah
she didn't invite me that piece of [ __ ]
I don't something over there was kind of
saying I'm not put Mary Shepard we were
on both Shack we were all in those
classes that's I nobody ever offered us
anything so my first acting class was
Frank Magna okay Frank Magna was if you
bring his name up the dice nice to look
at your ugly Frank Magna is one of those
Italians that you can't mention Andrew
Dice Clay around why hold it he loses
his mind like in a good way or a bad way
Frank magnet was like a writer and he
wrote something for hand you all clicked
it I don't know what the story is
although the guy was furious when I went
in there he's like whoa we'll make cuz
how do I call him in those days you
ought to call him okay and then I
remember when I first went the first
place I walked into was on Sierra Bonita
it was a little [ __ ] dingy place
small unless you will and then ask and
the guy made you buy the book audition
oh yeah I still have I still have that
book audition sometimes I reread and he
you got to go home and read it and then
call him I'm paying 275 hours eight
weeks and [ __ ] and there was easy
monthly payments and I'm like [ __ ] you
and then Frank Magna wizard toy is yeah
toy time you got the toy to walk to the
corner you know you have to guitar sit
on that side you look up and two doors
later it's still there okay I'm his wife
past
but my business I think he's still
moving this way maybe I'll have ties
come by with oh my god what the hell in
those days rather meet with them and
they would interview you and [ __ ] I get
they were legit like they were legit Lee
trying to steal your money and totally
would ask you what is your purpose of
this mission
and you would say I'm gonna be an actor
and I'm a stand-up nothing when I said
stand up he looked at me he goes okay
I'll give you a shot but the first time
you mess up you're out of here
you know stand-ups are a little oof I'm
not really a fan of stand-up to becoming
actors Robin Williams kind of pulled up
whatever but doesn't like stand-up
acting because I try to work you know
what we we have it going on it was good
but the only problem was it was Monday's
from 7:00 you can't don't when this was
the hottest night now I haven't 97 oh
yeah II know the Laugh Factory sold-out
headlined by Pablo and [ __ ] forward
those guys freaky Monday at The Improv
which was huge
freaky Monday was like [ __ ] the it
was it wasn't as big as a black show as
they had the Comedy Store at the time
with the with the Tories and it wasn't
450 yeah yeah
this one was packed fast Tuesday's okay
yeah Fat Tuesday was the store yeah but
Monday if you could get on at the Empire
Kimmy walked out of there with a card he
says some eight day twenty it was Josh
wolf we knew them poker so we got in
early
yeah yeah and it was like Josh wolf me
somebody else in the store and then Dave
Attell no Pablo
somebody big that was white with Roman
yeah and destroy the room and then the
black guy will come up uh and then they
would take over the room it was booked
by Gersh at the time oh boy nurse ran it
but that really that's the improv was
all industry industry at that time so
you walked in there on a Monday you
better bring your A game
you were we would walk out of there with
something and the same across town at
the Laugh Factory it was Latino night
400 deep yeah people hanging off the
sides probably and see it would go into
the place would blow I have I yeah it
was just it was great was a different
day and then you went to the comedy
store was an open mic yeah so if you
need to do a triple crown on the Monday
can was like getting your dick sucked by
a guy with ice cubes in his mouth I'm
saying like that's what that that's what
it was like leave remembering matter I I
just don't know how to I don't want to
hear the story behind what it's funny
because Eleanor was sitting behind the
sidelines watching all this yeah I was
waiting tan this is what's interesting
that you're watching the that you know
like I was talking about James Steve is
the third oh one day Paul I only used to
call James Stevens the third oh yeah and
I was telling the story they bring him
up he would he would get standing over
the change was terrific absolutely
terrific you know and as a stand-up as a
school from the traditional stand up you
hate that [ __ ] yeah okay you hate props
you hate all that [ __ ] like on the
traditional stand up right I'll be alive
like I don't want to see a prop I don't
want to see you drinking your hand on
stage I don't know yeah I want you to do
straight up [ __ ] comedy so I'm gonna
I was like this is what this is what the
frustrations you go through his economy
like people that sing on stage I hate it
that look a lot it killing the land it
kills me I'm like it someone in Tulsa
Oklahoma if a guy goes up there and sing
songs will it kill I don't listen
whatever makes them laugh and whatever
makes them feel good now at this point I
understand
James Steve is a third we'll go up there
do a little bit of comedy play the organ
and then going to saw his voice was
brilliant yeah he said he did great song
really comedic sozin um not really not
really but he would get a standing
ovation then I remember anyone up there
with my Eddie Griffin easel let's keep
it all for James demons to tear it yeah
they always did it I don't know if he
know this is de st. the singing stores
the [ __ ] commies done people
hated it there was a lot and then you
have he's hide people still hate it like
we pray props and I'm lying to you that
I'm telling you because I appreciate the
yard
Heath hydras a car
that had this brilliant that at the end
the wings would get attached to it but
the gospel the gospel saying isn't black
people singing and clapping and there
was twenty people behind them clapping
it was our faces it was alright it was
great it was great Mitzi had a great
eyes and that bizarre and that was just
you went down in you got a following you
go [ __ ] he was brilliant
you done as he's cleaning the stage and
you're walking out he's still pulling
his props behind the curtain you're like
come on buddy let me try to let me get
this girl you're done these are all the
experiences but you saw this Allen law I
know it I used to helped Heath pull his
[ __ ] props in because it was so many
Harry basil - they would [ __ ] run
around and flip around on stage that's
right I brought him down the brain he
did Harry is too late the guy who does
the watermelon Gallagher did he ever go
to the storm yeah yeah my poncho because
when I first started he was doing it he
was doing a show in the main room and
unfortunately it didn't draw a lot but
they gave us Poncho's to wait tables and
I was like what about the drinks are
there gonna be like pieces of watermelon
and whatever else he's smashing in the
drinks and they're like no don't worry
about it just wear your poncho so I
still have my Gallagher poncho and it
has his name all over it like amazing oh
yeah
the [ __ ] guy that with the with the
puppet both of them Oh both of them I'm
a big fan the one guy here hates that
guy with the puppet for my cuz he makes
82 million dollars wait wait there's one
that you're not Jeff Dunham Jeff Dahmer
Andrew doesn't know him there's another
one in Vegas that got a deal from
America's Got Talent
I think I can't think of his name it
every time we voice or everyone also
knew the other guy that had the puppet
and yeah we literally Tyler and Lester
oh he had a dick and people would do
lines of coke off the puppets dead sure
like well I don't in George Otto and
George and I am selling against this guy
but have you seen the one from America's
Got Talent wears like a dragon suit in
his little
Chihuahua and I see him on comedy club
calendars like when I go to look if he
sells tickets man they're gonna take us
all tickets it's a business and salon
Amelia's get bad some committees a gig
to that yeah you I'm not going that club
of a support like I'd never forget when
that when the first reality shows is
marrying a millionaire yeah that one was
a comic but he it was out of the game
already he lived in Portland and his
closing joke he would let his pants on
fire and he would say is it me or is it
hot in here or something I swear to god
he would lie these pants on fire here's
something crazy sometimes these genes
are turned on sometimes they would
[ __ ] laugh so when he went on
America's whatever this is 98 our star
circuit I'm 87 mispriced our search or
something no no no wasn't started this
is a married show then I find that he
really wasn't a millionaire he was a
wire I was a realtor that didn't really
because he it was a realtor matter girls
who thought he was a millionaire he went
on the road but started selling out so
The Improv the book-of-the-month
Wednesdays and Thursdays if they became
a millionaire they took a [ __ ]
Thursday from Chimel Joe Millionaire Joe
million oh my god oh that's that's
respected by three Thursdays from chef
oh that's severe distress on it's my
first time working with Shamu I'm in
Miami I'm opening that one of his
greatest I'm opening up for this
boo-boo-chh on the Thursday night who
likes his pants on fire people cheering
a bunch of hot women
why aren't you hot women I'm dying a
dead-eyed slow death the dicks okay
because they're there to see him yes 95
year old and the next thing you know I
[ __ ] I get up the next morning and I
go to the improv and the management is
livid yeah I know what's going on
they're like [ __ ] Robert Schimmel
he called he canceled via fax ten
minutes ago Oh Robert said if you want
to [ __ ] with my money I'll [ __ ] with
your money and he cancelled Don Resta
song but he's brilliant and so weird
when you decide
to stand up for yourself when you're a
comedian yeah you have to I started
standing up for myself like in 99 was
when I started standing up for myself
and going wait a second
that's a nice Lorna yeah it's got to
change a little bit like you got to give
me an extra 50 bucks or whatever you
know yes and it's really weird when you
watch the documentary we were talking
about listen how well it's get it kept
evolving but they kept growing in the
music writing kept getting better but
then they did something and this is what
defines you as a as a [ __ ] artist
they went to the Edinburgh Music
Festival and they were slated to open up
for the stone right which that's how the
word became worldwide mm-hmm they didn't
get the memo
like I said they had that hot hot box
yeah it would rehearse at and if you see
them with 80s and 77 in Oakland they're
playing like they're in Napa in that box
but they don't like they don't see the
18,000 yeah it's giant they just and
that's what this art is about yeah to do
a show to put 100 percent in whether you
do a show for eight people that's Act or
18 and when you see that video we'll
play it after the show you watch it you
go wow I get what they would have and I
didn't know about that red-hot house
that hot house or whatever they called
this right I was like when they did
Sweet Home Alabama he said I came in one
morning and the one guy little late I
started playing opposite him and but the
thing that defined them was when they
went to Edinburgh or Edinburgh or to
[ __ ] the music they don't even say it
right and they came out and the rule was
not to walk on the tongue yeah it was a
song for the Rolling Stones
that was the rule not to go out of the
tongue and he didn't give a [ __ ] he took
the guitar playing walk on the tongue
they said Mick Jagger was very very
angry right there they blew the phone
our stones had nowhere to go
course if you watch that before yeah you
like the stones policy door them up
there smoking cigarettes yeah you had a
bow on they knew it they had just seen
something that was real like those
people
like they closed with wonderful Freebird
and it was it when you closed the free
bird it's very tough to follow that
that's like Joe Rogan's Nicole Smith bit
yeah thank God we were done it was done
don't even just do your best
I love how you said free bird builds
from like an eight-minute song sometimes
it would be at 1 15 20 minutes I'm like
holy [ __ ] but that's like building a bit
the same thing but talk about that hot
box thing like I learned that from DICE
he taught me like whether whether you're
in front of 20,000 people or eight
people always give them the show like
you're in front of up you know 20,000
people no matter what well the late
nights at that's originally 15 people
yeah that's what it was
I do not believe that I was doing
stand-up around town for 40 people at
night now I'm a regular at the store and
I'm actually going up at 10:00 the
[ __ ] 2 for 8 people that's what I did
my life go away it's 10:00 to 2:00 and
there's eight people and I'm going up on
stage and you have a choice to make
yeah you can go up there with your
stupid [ __ ] material that everybody's
heard on that one yeah or just talk to
them and see I'm feelin yep I think you
seek a diamond the diamond shows up I
don't think it going up there one night
this is no no I was up there [ __ ]
coked up one night I took some chick
that are back after I do my sets I guess
[ __ ] up oh I thought you meant before
no no I thought you meant while you were
on stage that's that's really impressive
I would always having in my pocket brag
on my box as I walked off that stage
that was a great set too great I would
go right for that bathroom ba-ba-ba-ba
him and then I go see the Korean guy on
his teeth would come out of his mouth
oh you mean now Huck I give up I give
him a couple lines ago and his teeth
would get stuck it's false teeth with a
cocaine is good I cannot feel nothing I
wouldn't give him a couple lines of coke
and that means I drank for free the
whole night and now it's all here oh my
god oh yeah and I give them another line
of code and that'd be doing double jacks
coke smoke and [ __ ] cigarettes are
you kidding me or what that's
the stories about Jack fast Chuck was
the man yeah I did those late nights I
just last night I went on and I was beat
to [ __ ] because it just came back from
Oklahoma I'd done a podcast and I had
another set like a little shitty bar
whatever but then I went to the store
and it my friends are like oh you got
two more than you I'm like all right
whatever I know like you're gonna stay
I'm like yeah I'm gonna stay but I'm not
gonna leave they booked me so I weighed
it and I'm telling you it was I would
say 18 people phenomenal enough there
was people from Norway England like
there's this girl from Norway so funny
she came up to me and she was like you
all so funny yeah like I didn't know
they had black people in Norway oh no I
still love people doing beautiful others
don't want to go home yeah extent the
Hyatt so they don't want to go home
don't you
I'm gonna forget one that I wasn't where
we were from Denmark and I did a book
report idea I [ __ ] die on the place
[ __ ] like that comes out of he loved
everybody
I was coked up I took a girl to the back
room and I said this is where the
bathroom is she was was that like a car
like every Monaco and then I walked
outside something happened that I walked
outside she said where you going
and she stripped naked and got on that
little Houdini couch in the bathroom the
best is low that's old-school they put
that in there for women to rest she
started playing with a [ __ ] in there
right I name you [ __ ] was coming out of
but you're going there playing real hard
what did you see in yata she had like a
bush of hair that I sniffed half of it
like I gave him a little sniff or
something I just whacked off in the face
light walked into her limo she have a
good eye she was part of like a girls
night out like that that we get married
on Saturday it was amazing but my point
of the story that I went home look like
that chick had yahooeys [ __ ] a book the
next night I went on stage and there had
to be eight people and I really wanted
to try this joke but that [ __ ] was so
ugly I had to talk about it and I'm like
[ __ ] was so ugly it looked like any
Munsters teddy bear Wolfie I'll never
forget that
Wolfie really look like Chewie the door
guy oh my god like [ __ ] like that was
what came out of you could you go for
tea yeah
you're like I had I mean you bet your
guy row yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] there's no
people real dick around yeah they're not
gonna go for that joke and I'm gonna get
my feelings hurt you no matter how bad
you don't like this joke it's gonna kill
you try that [ __ ] at nine
o'clock is at that two o'clock is gonna
die forget that new material I'll start
talking from the heart they're [ __ ] up
at two how long did it take you guys to
figure that out though years a long time
years years that not going anywhere so
can you read in audience now like I
think I can I have to look up in jujitsu
they give you a black belt and for every
year you're a black belt every three
years they give you a red stripe and I
always tell people honest honest honest
to god I'm not as good as my technique
is but I know the clown he gained so
well now 27 yeah as you know I started
watching dice SHhhh I rented the halfway
house room well that was the halfway
house now oh and a half okay yeah two
rooms that was for rent for New Year's
and nobody was a no no I'm a big party
you didn't drink no no yeah so I said
[ __ ] it let me rent till I got a nice
Clay's tape I was not doing stand up to
him and I put the tape in the New Year's
and me I hated it I got weights and
Chinese food in the pizza and that's
what we did on New Year's we couldn't go
out and watch the Andrew Dice Clay but
before I got on stage
I watched hours of standing up like what
once I watched the movie with Tom what
is this Tom Hanks okay yeah yeah like
that was it that was in my whole mind
yeah I'm elated by stand-up I watched
his much stand-up and I knew who I liked
and who I didn't like and what styles
you like that's what before you get on
stage that's what you did yeah you did a
same yeah for a little while you watch
these comics you like I like Tom servo
but then you see him and like there was
a lot of times you tell me you went to
see atomic and you went to see him one
time he was really good but the next
three times he sucked the bag of dicks
that's why I started learning from Lee
telling me little things from a fan
perspective right the same way you did
you we were talking whatever so now when
you get on stage it's a lot easier
that's what I didn't have
yeah like we have to really
knowledge how lucky we are as comics
because you had a family when you jumped
in mm-hmm I did yeah I always tell
people yeah definitely for I don't once
I got to the store is where I started
pickin up well yeah I mean I picked a
few guys up along the road like Jerry
Roca who I'm gonna have one oh isn't he
terrific he's terrific but I wanted to
tell his I think that the Rogen
explosion and the comedy explosion is
making a lot of young comics very
confused it's making young comics not
see the work we were kids yeah your mom
the teacher used to go I want to see the
work I want to see 5528 times eighteen
come on yeah you just gave her a number
that means you didn't do the work that's
a see the one over the one the two over
the two
yeah I don't think that people really
understand the cultures of this business
like you've been doing it how long for
now a little over 11 years and you were
student in the game foul 12 okay it's
obviously 23 of but you've been around
it yeah you know the ins in huh you saw
pit bulls hmm
plus you saw people come and people go
you saw stars get made yeah and stars
but I saw you guys put the work and I
saw you put the work and I saw Joe Rogan
put the work and like people somebody
wrote on my thing Oh Sherri Shepherd's a
comic now I'm like no no Sherri
Shepherd's being a comic for a long time
like that she was there when I first
started at The Comedy Store she was one
of the hot comics at the store putting
the work in and then she got on the view
and got into all that and maybe the
stand-up subsided for a minute but she
never stopped like doing it now she's
doing it and somebody was at oh really
now Sherri Shepherd's a comic I'm like
no she was no work and she was banging
her head up there when they were savage
yeah Sherri Shepherd's got big breasts
those comics were going crazy oh yeah
but she was always a Christian you know
it's you
all the girls you know Lisa Jones things
Rita Jones is still doing you know it
takes a lot people have no idea how hard
it is just to be a comedian my moment
comic and again I'm not being gender
biased or whatever it's tough the road
has to be the roughest thing for a woman
unless you're self-confident yeah you're
it's really hard to road for a woman I
can see how hard it is for a guy to see
how hard is for a guy with a family but
for a woman you know I'm less you know a
nobody alley woman had a bit about it
yeah she doesn't particularly like going
on the road you know she gets picked up
at a hotel by somebody she doesn't know
and taken back by somebody she doesn't
know what that she's a hotel room yeah
yeah yourself the hotel knows you're in
that hotel room you know I know I
thought of that this weekend you know
I'm half a gangster myself and because
I'm always looking for a fight but in my
head I couldn't we were in a little
shitty hotel that I booked cuz Andrew
let me do the road managing which he'll
probably never let me do again anyway I
booked the shitty hotel and I couldn't
figure out how to turn the lights on so
I made the guy at the front desk in the
middle of nowhere Fort Smith Arkansas
come up in the room and show me no and I
was like oh yeah this is probably how it
happens and I thought I'm looking around
for weapons now like why I put that I
made this guy come in my room Andrews
three doors down you know he's not
paying attention he doesn't know what
the [ __ ] could happen but then when he
left I was like then we get to the venue
and you're talking about women on the
road they were like I they go who's the
opening act ankle I am they go no no
seriously I'm like what I'm like no I am
they go oh we thought you were Andrews
girlfriend I'm like wow that was 15
years ago we weren't right now I'm gonna
do some jokes and they're like okay do
you do you need anything I'm like what
do you mean do I need no I'm a comic
I'll do it up good and then afterwards
the guy was like sucking my dick like oh
my god and expect that and I'm like
really
like why would you demean someone just
because she's feet whatever like he was
like oh I didn't think you could speak
like what year is it for you I really
give Andrew props
on his treatment of you like uh a member
may I don't remember him hit monster
Burmese oh my god running from him see
you get into his car like you are on the
fence for a while shall I suck his dick
Sheila please don't please stop hitting
on me there was a stop and you started
dating me you know wear you down bro
ladies if you're listening he will get
it if he wants it and that's who he is
exits following that he stayed your
friend yeah he's my best thing he helps
me with everything and he's guided you
and that's what makes us better comics
when I see the Theo Vaughn's and I see
the [ __ ] I saw him four years ago I've
been back at the store for years mercy
oh wow
well she's five so I'm back there five
years or something like that's 1014 and
years and I think how to get re value
you know I still remember re being a
[ __ ] phone guy oh yeah around argue
with each other now that these [ __ ]
superstars are these you love seeing
that they'll [ __ ] love it I love it
how can you not love it and then when
dice was going through that divorce
which I didn't believe which is why I
wouldn't accept it when he hit on me I
was like I know your wife go back to
your wife stop messing around this is
not you you're not this person whatever
he was really going through a divorce
and I didn't believe it and he would
come to the store and he would film us
do you remember that like he was making
a reality show and so re was the star of
it Steve Rannazzisi Simone
Mike black me Katie Seabury like any but
Ari's was the best like Ari would he
would make him skateboard or throw him
down a flight of steps fall off his
skateboard
beat him up have his kids beat him up it
was constant he's gonna start putting
those tapes out on YouTube cuz they're
old school we he was trying to sell them
but it never sold it wound up being our
reality show was a dice undisputed on
vh1 but all those tapes he's getting
changed all the lighting in the Comedy
Store cuz he was that crazy from going
through a divorce that he was like [ __ ]
I'm using my speakers he bought the
system he bought the system what the
system after he had a fight with Paulie
one time I don't know if Steve Simone
ever tells you the story but we were
having a meeting as staff me Simone I
think Simone was the manager back then
he was begging to get out of it and
paulie's leading the meeting and he's
yelling at us and then dice comes in
they get into a huge fight huge fight
screaming at each other and then he
walks out and this [ __ ] Sam Kinison
look-alike walks in the back of the room
Steve and I both of us nearly just
passed out like what the [ __ ] just
happened that they wake up Sam Kinison
right now like it was the weirdest thing
and he really hey Pauly I'm just coming
in and say hi the Sam Kinison look-alike
and we were like what the [ __ ] is but
that's the day Andrew put the speaker
system in was when he had the fight with
Pauly in the original in the original
room yeah then Rogan did something
original because those speakers I think
blue yeah the ones Andrew bought but
Andrew took the old ones that have been
there for 20-some years 25 years or
something like that
he took them and he has them in his
house but they still work they just
weren't good enough so he he bought him
and then Brogan bottom Eddie Griffin
used to do benefits so we could have a
roof that was another thing every time
any would do the main room he's like is
this for the roof or can I keep to check
what the [ __ ] you know I kept putting
showmen reef in the place with the leak
you walked into the Comedy Store the
[ __ ] tire cold you got to walk around
if I was a real drug with a slip and
it's kind of deal with in those days I
never thought about it there was always
of rain bro [ __ ] it yes my customers
with tables she was too cheap to put a
roof on it so like a real risk you would
send a little Mexican get up one callers
with a scalpel and that [ __ ] stuff
that you just put on there
it's Derek I want that one Natalie not
in it cuz I know about Rufus no way we
feel it K yeah it was paver there Juan
Carlos what did you use this is a
trampoline they finally put the roof on
there I don't think so I don't know yeah
yeah
because of that it would have been Mitzi
always may want Carlos do it and he
would come to her ego the problem is
miss Mitzi I'm not an electrician you
know and she let me be like covered cuz
he got burnt trying to [ __ ] Allah
Allah
trying to put electric phase assembly I
used to have to go cuz I took all Jack's
job oh that's a runner it was it was a
shock it was Freddy's job that Freddy
gave it to oh sure mm-hmm then Baba was
Shaq well food to me two days a week I
think like Monday and I would have to
gather a tongue sandwich from
Greenblatt's Greenblatt's
all would have to go to hamburger Hamlet
and bring her food I would have to go to
the bench in chin chin and I would have
to go to the hardware store
yeah the one that they charge you to 94
hours for a screw ace harp the one on
Santa Monica Santa Monica is Gabe no
wait yes ace ace is the chain then
probably not anymore now what's gonna
know it's still there and aisles are
real narrow and they got everything you
need go get this you need for one Carlos
so how was it runner yeah I don't forget
one Friday I went she ever send you to
air one go to air one give me some
peanuts almonds no never once I had one
I went to I've been warned and when they
gave me 100 over on the deposit thank
God I counted it ah hell I [ __ ] took
the yardstick and then they call me a
daily really was that the positive hon
you know whatever you gave me I gave to
the tower so they were calling the
talent the talent the Holy Smoke
it was already long gone you know saying
you made a mistake here angel a no Tommy
either
ain't no sticky-fingered Tommy but he
put a yardstick over I gotta tell you
you always got a double checkers I
wouldn't want them to say we gave you
nine that was eight so Joey stole it so
right in front he had counted I counted
it twice in front of Manuel this dumb
[ __ ] for the next day yardstick in there
alright thank you
a day later he's like man I know and
then I got blamed for the cigarettes her
cigarettes yeah you said they used to
buy cigarettes and put in the front
I used to date Carol at the time when I
first moved to town yeah I was just a
dirty [ __ ] but carol was just way
Cleveland at it would be out in the hold
long hair yeah really pretty girl yeah
but that was just the fur if you didn't
know Carol me when I first saw Carol I
know she was a dirty [ __ ] like I was
talking to him right away she went right
for it she's like I don't know what to
do tell her when I met her in Michigan
okay this is the conversation I ain't
doing everything like comedians I saw
this comedian in Jamaica and I really
liked that and then I come to comedy
shows more often and she's like I can't
go home tonight because my boyfriend's
gonna beat me or something like that so
I said you just stay in my room she's
like okay it was that easy when you do
that you just have [ __ ] filthy air on
it and I sold it on the double bed I go
there's two beds yeah I jump over you
would pop I'm lonely you have double
beds yeah there was talk this is an old
like this club had class they put you
like some sweets like before that this
was Crestwood suites ism and there was
two rooms in the bed and I started the
messing around with the first night
nothing really bad happened but the next
day she wanted to write for the
Kalamazoo that's gonna come on yeah drop
your pants and drive [ __ ] so I drove
up with a [ __ ] panties on the whole
way Quigley like eight miles I'd make a
play with a [ __ ] play with your [ __ ] a
little bit for uncle Joey's you can just
beat that little bat up on her she had
those little dirty feet hanging out of
the [ __ ] Larry is hilarious but I
loved I loved it she was good play with
a [ __ ] in the car while you smoking
reefer that's that's sure that's a good
friend yeah it was a keeper that's a
good girl
so we moved out here she would go to the
store you know move together yeah yeah
Michigan she came at the boulder a week
later okay I've been me and her and her
brother went camping and I was stabbing
her in the tent right next to a brothers
he's yelling and screaming the poor
brothers sleeping by himself she was an
animal
she had no [ __ ] class who [ __ ] with
every brother next to you in the tent
I'm over there sticking it to a
fingering up her ass yeah she's gone
I don't like your brothers next does
that you know and give a [ __ ] what type
of sleep do you have gosh I didn't I
didn't I wasn't thinking I may be only a
[ __ ] why maybe jerk off into a belly
button something like nice and easy but
no she won't have to [ __ ] do it and
I'll make you brothers right next to I
don't give a [ __ ] and as soon as I just
put thank you ahh I'm I shut the [ __ ] up
your brother's next door you think you
know [ __ ] that's when you know you're an
animal you [ __ ] thanks to your brother I
know a lot of girls that did that to my
brothers while I was asleep right there
they would just have sex right there in
front of me I've been sleeping my mom
like on the couch or something my
brothers would have a girl on the floor
and then I'd see her outside Dunkin
Donuts and I'm like I know you if I give
myself if I give me 2000 edibles me
passes I'll give you a stamp on the
couch good all right Lee that's how to
do it can we keep the cameras on it how
fun is that if you actually wake
somebody up and go you were so passed
out [ __ ] somebody funny oh yeah I
guarantee I could get that [ __ ] up on
animals you know you're halfway there no
I'm really not that like trust me agent
your eyes aren't even open well that
just kind of happens yeah the [ __ ]
batch of death urban trees over Ventura
Boulevard he's got this [ __ ] call
[ __ ] kill yourself slowly ah it's
like 26% it's the Bourdain [ __ ] blend
- youngsaeng
this reefer is deadly you don't want to
kill the goat go but urban trees tell
him uncle Joey sings I tell him to give
you the same thing Joey got it's like
glue Mendocino something it was like
super glue kind of like a super glue
yeah you said a case like super glue
yeah that's what we sprinkled in and
afterwards shot some heroin in there let
me ask you a question yes it's part of
the toughness you acquired for calmly
growing up with [ __ ] ten brothers and
sisters in a two-bedroom Philadelphia
definitely you gonna sleep on a couch
here in this hotel room reserved right
I've lived in the corner the roaches
crawl I got a couch tonight that's a
[ __ ] wait all the cushions are on the
couch there's no stains there's no semen
stains on the pot what was the worst
problem there you say that the worst
condo used to La Jolla was up there but
the one at Tempe improv was pretty nasty
to those roaches everywhere really yeah
it was pretty nasty at the end it was a
singer it was a single yep up the corner
mm-hmm
yeah we used to I think it's just over
the years god I remember being panicked
like [ __ ] there's roaches in here cuz
you know growing up my mom was like if
you see roaches you know you gotta let
me know cuz they spread they drop eggs
and whatever like dirt road to a day
anxiety that my mom gave me growing up
with dirt roaches there was a lot in
that condo I was afraid the shower it
was a lot it was everywhere it was bad
that condo was pretty nasty but that was
about 10 years ago
well almost 11 years ago cuz damn Murr
had me come and a host for Dave Attell
and I was like yeah I'll do it and I
have a day job at the time and I told
the guy all man has terrible stomach flu
and I drove to Phoenix to do our Tempe
to do the hosting for Dave and when I'm
sitting in the greenroom
@l comes in and he's like what are you
doing here cuz he knew me from the
Comedy Store waiting tables and Mitzi's
assistant whatever but he goes do you
work here now and I was like no I'm
doing stand-up he's like get the [ __ ]
outta like and then I got to host for
him and then I was such a big fan of a
tell I was giving him giant intro and
he's like hey you got a knock I can't
follow the intro you got to calm down
all right all right
so I'll just give like two things you've
done because I was given like he had a
great set 98 store you know what I mean
like my memory was just jogged with like
every girl rate was at the store 98
[ __ ] loved him he would crush
work for him so much when I was a
feature and he would tell me what you
doing is good because what how is this
level he saw the husband or yeah he was
drinking but he was still positive in
comedy like dude keep doing that yeah
whatever
he's always always very positive and
always told you to do what you do mm-hmm
I don't give a [ __ ] of you courage
because yeah at that time I was working
a lot on the road and I had a problem
once a month
yeah once a month like people a comic
oleynik yeah what's this rock Bob and
Ron show nobody cried Bob and Tom Bob
and Tom nobody cried more than those oh
yeah when I would work in front of
nobody nobody canceled be more than
those guys and back as a boat awful 98
99 when they were all big shots yeah Bob
and Tom dudes 99 2000 2001
I still remember long as yard they
wouldn't put me on why because it's like
the dude from Omni pop that left Omni
pop years ago they both hated me because
they were booking that features as
headliners v-rooms yeah that was at the
store yeah follow Mooney every night I
would go into our killers yeah we're
going to those rooms on the road and
[ __ ] level them I still don't being
in Michigan and Grand Rapids Michigan
and when I got off the guy came up he's
like I don't my name is John yella that
was spectacular he goes it was funny
because the featured the headliner was
at the bar drinking and he goes I went
and got the headliner and go do you know
what you have to follow look at that
time yeah design like penitent because
at that time I was already a regular at
showcase for misty
and what had happened was I went into
the store I wanted to The Improv on a
freakin Monday mmm I thought I was hot
[ __ ]
I really really holistic I like
tolerably I thought I was hot share I
was doing comedy eight and a half years
I was rolling in two rooms
I had Taco Bell commercial and I had a
toilet okay I had made a little money
but now I was still a [ __ ] junkie the
only guy that didn't like me was Jamie
Masada permits he liked me and Richard
Cooper who is the Booker at he was a
[ __ ] booth to do those notes so the
first time he saw me doing cocaine jokes
he came right
oh he's like do call it the spots so I
was regular at The Improv and at the
store within a month when I got here
that's amazing no within six months you
ain't like it takes you about not as
their full yet takes about nine months
to get the rhythm at the store you
borrow a lot you really start like wait
a second Betsy passed me but now I mean
index I just came from a restaurant I'd
leveled mmm yeah the store so now you
have to learn how to work the store yeah
takes you about nine months to adjust
the followings the the bump yeah yeah I
should learn what's he gonna check yeah
then you go go one way go the other way
my ego decide to go to one one okay
oh my god oh and I had I got a spotter
freaking one day where I shouldn't have
been okay at that time I would stay at
the store and smoke till 2:00 and I
would just park the car and wait till
4:00 and then I would drive to high bar
and there was a company I bought between
Hollywood Boulevard and Franklin
whatever that street is mm-hmm
that sold screws nuts and bolts on the
phone so oh yeah that's what you were
doing I would have to be there before to
call the contract codes Coons hardware
this is a different company I know I
came in there I did that for a while and
then that guy I used to send my avails
drew that that's what everything was the
facts everybody wanted your avails yeah
so I would send out 20 avails Monday 20
avails Tuesday the different Club oh oh
you know my name is Joey Diaz I'm gonna
set my paper and I'm a regular at the
store I've been in the pilot Bronx
County on CBS and they also got the Taco
Bell commercial drunk I'd love to play
your club as a feature act all right
acting me it and I give my pager number
and I drank my calendar out I put the
calendar out the year
oh yeah and I just make updates which is
bad in hindsight because well in those
days they couldn't really go to a
website right and see if you were at
that Club right so I would make sure
that that guy didn't know that guy who'd
pray to God that you don't know I was
yeah
feature of falador and I would tell you
that you follow me or I would call you
know hey man I'm gonna do a Eleanor's
room in Grand Rapids Michigan no I
stopped at Eastham I mean and yeah yes I
was hustling that's how you hustle yeah
I get paid 75 from you I take that 75
and I stay an extra night yeah and I go
do a guess out of the club now you got
you booked the club and you booked
another club mm-hmm where were you
working that Europe that was a Toledo
funny boat what did you do that and see
I'm gonna feature you BAM just did you
stay an extra night and drove for three
hours
it's really weird how the system worked
but I would sell those screws and then
one of the guys quit and he took me with
him to sell investments in Chuy's
building is that building there up on
the 11th floor I bet a newsstand
these [ __ ] idiots had like this
cartoon they were trying to sell but
they were already selling the guitar for
the cartoon player it was just too much
and they were trying to get those
investments where if you lose your money
you lose it oh that's a call this is
something for that people actually leave
money out yeah whose money it's a
write-off but they were looking for
$50,000 oh Jesus oh yeah h quo is
$50,000 but they paid me 15 an hour so I
didn't give a [ __ ] if I sold one they
gave me 20% which there was so you were
cold calling an investment in a TV show
yeah for a TV network pilot to get
investors for this movie that's a [ __ ]
up phone oh yeah it was a the guy that
ran the office was on Knots Landing he
was like a regular on Knots Landing it
was canceled by ten years at this point
it's so weird like this is what I did I
had a day job and then yeah I did spots
and they had a day job and it's fast
saying it will all did that yeah we I
got we all worked the store at one point
cuz you never really make money in the
beginning like you're saying that's $75
but then you had to spend that $75 so
you go home with a nickel like all
[ __ ] well it doesn't matter because I
got a week of work from him
working him so I mean invest in myself
that's what this whole thing when you're
in our this is all about investments
absolutely it's investing in yourself
and how much you want to invest into
some if you invest fifty percent of
something you're gonna get fifty percent
pay back yes yeah forty percent if you
invest on hundred and ten percent you'll
get back to ten if you really invest in
the right different opportunities
what's telling you better that got
accepted oh [ __ ] where it is Tony I want
to take this chance really fast to just
say I'm really proud of Dean Delray
hopefully this podcast will come up by
the time this show comes on or you get
guys who go back and watch it Dean
Delray that's done this podcast 20 times
with me he's on Conan O'Brien tonight
yeah he sent the tape and and they
[ __ ] did it you know and he really
wanted Tonight Show but he sent the tape
and and there's a guy that you see
second before we started the podcast I
was talking about the next line up with
stars like now I've been here a long
time
mm-hmm I could see it I can see the
people who put the work and see it so I
see you up there feel is a different
comic I mean laughs years ago he started
sell tickets
you know [ __ ] who else are we talking
about who's right there Santa he's
knocking on the door he's gonna end up
getting something quirky on some network
about [ __ ] in Puerto Ricans bro how
about when the drums history is titles
trail I think I never laughed so hard
watch the documentary last night when
the drummer said he hit he didn't hit of
acid and he was sitting next to a guitar
player and all of a sudden a monkey came
rollerskating in and sat next to them
and the monkey grabbed a bottle of Jack
Daniels drinking the Jack Daniels and
the guys like Here I am tripping my ass
off on that how's it going I got a hold
on here I'm sitting with a monkey who
just rollerskating in here and he's
drinking a bottle of Jack Daniels listen
that [ __ ] only happens when you do the
acid that the universe tells you
something that's right for the
commitment to take a [ __ ] chance yeah
where you going where you gonna do ask
that I'll do acid with you I've never
done it
do you ever smoke weed
oh you don't go out of this place I'll
take them to house every month sometimes
REO put people in the wilderness you do
to me and Simone that's what Lee needs
Lee needs a good trip by himself to
really become come on Lee I'll do see
what they were doing
me you and Sally how they were right
music in the house they were waking 7:30
in the morning and one of them will go
out to the [ __ ] field and they would
tip over cow patties and get to the
psilocybin mushrooms and then [ __ ]
bring him into the house and cook making
tea and he goes that they would start
drinking the tea in from time to time
they would start tripping this [ __ ] like
that and that's how they roll all the
way I'm telling you you're gonna be a
comic you gotta remove the safety then
it's over yeah that Lisa they even be no
more you Lisa at the comedian though
that's how you really have to look
that's true you know you gave up a lot
you could have said you know what I'm
quit in the store I'm gonna marry the
first guy that comes along right have a
kid spit this out how old were you when
you decide to get into comedy uh 34 yeah
like me 20:38
yeah wait way too [ __ ] late wait she
was catching up to do look at Dean yeah
thank you started like hustling but it's
it's a matter of hustle it's a matter of
you know when he told me was giving up
his apartment to live like a nomad he
sold everything he owned yeah that's
that's yeah to doing that I'm just
because I just want out I just want to
work I just yeah this comes a point
wheeling you know what I'm not stopping
yeah no kids
I've not no boyfriend yeah I might as
well get up you know put the money in
the bank and go on the road and keep
doing this and then come here for little
batches three four weeks just to keep
alive yeah yeah who gives a [ __ ] people
rent out air B&B really so [ __ ] time
yeah yeah it's a different world out
there you know look at Dean I mean in
New York he's just this is it jumping on
the road with people it's the best you
know it's uh he called me last really
goes listen I can't do Boston with you I
feel really bad unless you gonna let me
do it I go listen I can't hire some
for one night oh yeah but not somebody
for two Koya
so I go do the forum with Bill yeah I
got Tomatoes a blessing are you kidding
me I mean yeah la for you know he's just
and he's from like right now he's
soaking it up like this is called
soaking it up he might go to the for me
in a bag of dicks doesn't care he's
gonna be stronger than that let's say he
goes out then destroys yeah we keep
getting stronger and that's some
momentum and that's what I think that I
think the podcast has a has let people
forget that yeah you know some people go
oh my god I didn't know you were
spider-man for yeah that was 2003 I know
it what line I auditioned I was 14
[ __ ] years ago how about you Colin
Schirripa to tell me that me and Don
Barrera are gonna audition for The
Sopranos and I get fired
cuz sure Ripa went to the producers I
never wanted to tell you that and then
we wanted to tell you who culture wait
say it again tell me what I'm doing
spider-man - okay I got 14 days on
spider-man - I don't know no when they
hired me they go you got one day July
31st 2003 I got a call in June they're
going to wardrobe okay
and well I said okay see if you like the
reverse away yeah we'll see you next
week yeah okay and I wasn't there they
kept going you're not shooting today
come back tomorrow you know should I
come back tomorrow you know what come
back next Tuesday
oh you're not shooting her and then the
guy would say you're too big so one of
those days I got a call from George and
walking and she goes Joey you got a spot
in the Sopranos ah big [ __ ] gonna give
you far too is it's two to four episodes
depending on how much they like you
okay go put on tape and send it to me so
I said do me a favor Jordan my wife is
at work and I'm at Sony can you fax it
to the Comedy Store I called the store I
got permission
they said faxing over I got them the
line and the guy goes home leave it
downstairs for me I think it was Duncan
it was a talent coordinator okay mm
maybe two or three okay next thing you
know why go to the [ __ ] store and I
see you and you go I don't know if you
know this your sides are inside for the
surprise I'm so excited you and Dom are
and I go I remember those yeah like okay
the next thing I go home I take the
sides I put the sides on tape it's like
a Wednesday I guess that day my mistake
you didn't know you called sure Ripper
just to give him a heads up that me and
Dahmer additionally she was already on
yeah okay and Schirripa went to the
producers cuz Schirripa didn't like me
why because in 97 see when 97 Joe
started taking me on the road and then
they took me to Vegas and she Ripper
said one lap I said I made a buck for
sure but didn't like me in the beginning
welcome like I called Joe and Joe goes
you want to hope with me the dirty show
ago yeah yeah he gave me a direct line
to call Schirripa bro I called Steve
Steve how you doing now I know a lot of
his friends yeah have said to me do you
know sure if he's gonna love you yeah so
when I call trippin like how you don't
man nice to meet you he's like who's dis
and a Joey D is I was told the coin he
goes let's cut this [ __ ] it's 200 it's
uh it was like two hundred for two shows
yeah he could be pretty direct I'm like
anything it's 200 for the show there's
no [ __ ] airfare and we give you off
card for the employee cafeteria I get
off the phone one and Rogin calls like
what you say that guy he's really pissed
off so we check into [ __ ] Vegas the
VIP and he calls drogon again and says
you know tell that dude to come to my
office I cannot stands in there like
just being weird to me it gives me like
the card he gives me employee dining
then midnight comes and we go upstairs
the place is sold out and play boys that
play boys do a show about dirty show at
night with comics then yeah different
kind late night right so I walk in you
know listen I just don't let people know
what it feels like you know and I know
Lee feels this at time is when I'm
walking somewhere with Lee they don't
even look at me like so I walked in
which row again I took Rogan and he goes
come here I wanna introduce you to the
play board people honor I am standing
like a Mook with eight the hills
I felt like a guy with the HIV you know
sailing I'm just standing there so I
went and got a table and sat got like a
soda and he came over and like you can't
sit there you know that was just one of
those things so he had a late just but
guess what I [ __ ] went up there from
the anger from how he treated me I
[ __ ] them destroyed that room for 15
minutes even surprised the roof didn't
fly off it dad like I said I was a
comedy store got the hang of it and I
knew what I was doing and Rogan went up
there and Rogan lost him like the
eight-minute mark somebody yelled
where's Phil Hartman that's [ __ ] up
and that was the beginning of the end
but the funny thing was the next day I
got a call in the hotel room Danny
Robbins he's my agent okay
and he goes dog the Playboy people going
back to see you tonight
oh it's great so short but clearly got
pissed off realest thing it was the
weirdest thing like I always tell people
because I know he could be a hard-ass
yeah it was always glad everybody's like
everybody in this life not everybody's
gonna like everybody yeah and sometimes
it happened to you you go you know what
that guy's in a powerful position and
him and AH more real time ya know about
that time domdom like neither he didn't
like you yeah okay
you know so at the time like I was
hanging out with rogue and a rogue
Mystics explained these guys he's a cool
guy
but every time I get off the stage Dom
would always go it's nice to see that
you're writing again and turning his
face on me well that's [ __ ] up
yeah I mean I was getting tortured these
days yeah you know what I didn't give a
[ __ ] and then I was gone with the
Italian audition so now they started
hating me oh yeah I'm going to get mad
at that Shelly you know with Andrew
anyway what was the guy that you used to
hang up there that had muscles and he's
funny he was a karate guy and he used to
take your finger very women versus men
and they're all there the whole we know
crew is there so bestest alongs brother
oh yeah they're all well and I walk
ilysm as
sign my name they're all like I hate
coming to Cuban kids let's all go home
here comes the fake Italian and I would
sit there and take the abuse and I would
go you know what I'm a book this mother
[ __ ] out of respect and I'll never
forget that Vinny wasn't analyzed this
he's the guy that ya threw out the
window yes so he's sitting there going I
got this with chess like I don't even
know why you guys are here because I'm
friends with Chaz oh that's funny and I
went in there just knock them walk that
chair and the next day when they called
me I'm like I won those the other
Italian guy cuz there was two of us that
yeah I don't know we have me and some
other guy throw a guy into the ocean
that was it that was the scene get
kidnapped I call we take him out of a
trunk yeah I remember that yes yes I got
that and they were [ __ ] few yourself
ah well see everybody's so sensitive
about that [ __ ] like I don't get bad if
somebody gets booked as an iron the
[ __ ] when I got the Longest Yard how
many Italians now main one wrote it or
thought yeah after the show oh my god I
just got oh I just got hit up from one
of his boys he wants to be on my podcast
of course if I wanted to be on his yeah
I cornered him once I said to him I saw
the letter you wrote on him Sam
he started started with his [ __ ] and I
wasn't even violent I just go I know I'm
not mad at you but Jesus Christ my
family you should be ashamed of yourself
I've never told nobody just to let you
know he was pale because that's the way
people are in this town they're very but
I would go to those auditions and so
look at that glares an election and it
would make me want to go and then dr.
[ __ ] boy you really oh now
watch my [ __ ] smoke
well you kill a name I'm I'm Tara I feel
terrible if I called her up and blew
that for you cuz you would have been
perfect on this door and I've been
watching this Sopranos right now like
what fall asleep I'm like I put the
Sopranos oh that's my [ __ ] it's the
brother remember when when Phil comes in
to get the car fixed and pussy's brother
comes out wiping his eyes and wasn't
around with your brother all that stuff
happened with your brother what happened
he goes it's a long story we don't like
to talk about it yeah but I still
remember those lines
it's a long story we don't want to talk
about it Europe is not even in that
scene like it was so funny because you
know what time Georgine called me to
fire me at 2:20 in the morning Los
Angeles time why she caught she called
me at 5:30 in the morning
New York New York time well that you
violated the breach of confidentiality
agreement I never know how to breach
confidentiality agreement she knows once
your addition those day is there a
really tough on you like but you haven't
gonna realty yes right man who would
have lines on it so they would be coded
so you couldn't steal the sheet yeah a
lot of people what to talk about an
audition that that mean that's that's
weird
yeah you can't it's a it's it's
sometimes it's very those places where
you going and you but check what you
write sign yeah because like now today
when you book something they give you an
extra sheet you have to sign and they
don't want you [ __ ] another winner
well could I get it yeah but if you're
just going in to read for it that's a
whole nother that doesn't make sense
oh no no of you like I'm you gonna take
a loan in that you had to do a
background check and they hired me so
the background system ain't that [ __ ]
good you don't think it's very like only
goes back six months I got three dollars
I'll carve up some [ __ ] I'm gonna forget
signing the background search release
and just going what am I gonna do like
what do i do do I go home and I go no
I'm gonna go in there [ __ ] their world
up yeah and I want a man [ __ ] that world
up and I go I'm not gonna get it because
the computers will come back kidnapping
and drugs right and the next day I told
the director no kind of thought in
Brasilia hmm you know I'm bad my record
you molest kids no you're good that was
just one no molestation no [ __ ]
sexual [ __ ] and you're good any sex that
I have no sex stuff on my creepy [ __ ]
record I got a couple thefts a couple
[ __ ] wrong possessions which weren't
really mind I never got concrete in fact
there's one that you were charged yeah
okay there's an arrest that I was doing
time in Colorado there's an arrest I got
in Fort Lee New Jersey that was in
Colorado doing time yeah I just haven't
bothered to take it off this what's the
use what you gonna do what
what's gonna make me a better individual
if I take off a [ __ ] coke possession
hyung give a [ __ ] you know and they ask
me is your character oh yeah that that
[ __ ] thing is dominant possession of
stolen tools possession of schools to
[ __ ] rob things yeah larceny I got
charged on larceny a couple times that's
tremendous I know what it means I just
like you got a car you got charges of
larceny I it's funny cuz right now
you're in this weird cusp and everybody
who is about to hit it always gets into
a weird cusp and you accept it like what
I was doing like that was weeks I was
headlining for nice money and then a
week way and I'd be [ __ ] I'm seeing
if the Joe Rogan that's how you do it
I'm back in my mind I know I'm just
getting better and I'm getting exposed I
featured Fordyce last weekend I'll go
home to Philly to you know I'm going
home for a little bit for taking a
couple days off go get some water I said
Italiano's like a person and then I'll
go and headline the parks casino out
there and you're there when September
5th I'm there September 14th oh oh
you're doing the big room I'm doing the
big was downstairs gotta start something
in your backyard that's right how'd they
get to you before helium uh well I do
helium but I feature it helium with you
I've done it with Dom I've done it with
a bunch of people but they never booked
me again like big changed hands or
something I don't know the girl that
used to book it she moved on to
somewhere else
because I headlined the Asheville Comedy
Festival last two years ago and that a
different girl that I met from helium
came so I was like oh and I gave her all
my info and they never they never
reached out I've reached out they've
never responded yeah you're on that cusp
that's it yeah you pick a momentum you
know I was like I said I was really
proud of you when they say on the Maron
podcast oh that was great yeah he was
fun that was fun and weak because he's
on Glo
so we talked a lot of wrestling [ __ ] you
know and he I introduced him to my guy
because the guy who does well or did
well whatever he still doesn't
I shouldn't say did it
the guy who does well he started glow
but he sold the rights so he's not
affiliated with that show it's just kind
of yes at the fluoride the form Dean del
Rey you're gonna kill it rather and then
we went to see you what else I go see
there we used to go to swatch schooi
perform truly was the best I was talking
about a few weeks ago the podcast : you
just thought he could part God you saw
play the [ __ ] song hey [ __ ]
tremendous he killed it but yeah the the
wrestling so now I do commentary for
well women of wrestling and at the
Belasco they do live shows they're gonna
do a live one in the 10th and 11th of
October and I'll be doing commentary on
the side I'm happy you came on today
thank you talk some [ __ ] it's a vacation
week go to Philly tomorrow I'm good
today really yep tomorrow morning and
what are you doing you get to Philly
what's the first thing the first thing I
do I go to my mom's stay my little
sister will pick me up at the airport
go to my mom's I'll go get a whole year
something probably just get lunch me
bring it home then we go to italiano
let's get water ice then I start to you
know bloat get sick a little bit then I
come down just hang with my family cuz
nobody left my mom still in the same
we're all home we grew up in my brothers
are up the street around the corner ETS
around the corner we might go to Ohio to
see my nephew we'll see what happens
oh I need more material so I gotta hang
out just to write I never take a week
off but I take a week off I feel because
I want I really want to go on I'm gonna
take it really Sam's room yeah thing but
you know what I gotta force myself to do
this to really be in love with I got two
weeks next week at the Laugh the ice
house on Saturday that's great don't
wall me up Philly
oh yeah I'm excited for you let me tell
everybody the 15th I'm at the 9:30 club
in DC so it's perfect like I just take
this week off right I need one more
something to get that set really after
going it's gonna be nice who's opening
Simone in Philly I am
Matt full Tron Oh trial we work together
a governor he worked with me max max
like you know he lives in he's terrific
he's terrific he's great to be around I
got nervous he asked could he feature
for me because I was headlining at
governor's and I'm like Voltron is great
and he was he was great but it was a fun
like hard follow you know any mean like
I was like okay he killed and this is
great but we would work together it was
great I loved that full job it's amazing
but when I shot that Netflix thing like
that wasn't even me what do you mean
person like of who what I'm doing on the
road now like I'm really happy that I
didn't crack a couple months ago I'm
really happy that sometimes you get your
phrases yep in all levels before year
more give it to you it's a roller
coaster roller coaster I had a coffee
yesterday when I arrived mmm you know
and just to see cuz Theo is always
taking care of himself in weird ways
I'm gonna call Theo and see if I need to
do the same thing or whatever yes it
gets too real sometimes yeah you gotta
tame it down uh-huh
and I know for you sometimes you've been
that well one week you're at a [ __ ]
bar in La Jolla next week you're on a
[ __ ] tremendous Club with Andrew yeah
and you have to like chess you know
pinch your finger
yeah and kiss yourself and say yourself
am I really [ __ ] the only this guy or
what
so yeah uh-huh go out and see Eleanor
September 5th at parks casino what time
is it show
Billy eight o'clock oh [ __ ] my Philly
girl comin out right
alright then I'll be there retweet lay
that the parks casino at Pelham [ __ ]
Friday night the 14th and then Saturday
September 15th I'm at the nine
[ __ ] 30 Club and that's it and
that's that
before you leave I just want to tell you
one thing it's football season and
everybody's looking to make a little
money and then to enjoys and help you
make a little money if you're smart you
can't be a [ __ ] degenerate yeah
remove has to be calculated like I said
since I started this podcast people
always ask for advice but when it comes
to gambling I can't I can't pick a team
to [ __ ] you know but the truth is I
don't know who's gonna win but if you
did you know you gotta check out my
boogie that's it remember who you're
betting on this is important
who you betting with that's why I always
tell people to bet with my bookie calm
trust me guys they're the best bet this
season they've been in business for
years they have great online reviews and
their mobile site is nice and easy to
use I would recommend the service to my
listeners that's been good to me that's
why I'm urging you to make your way to
my bookie you win they pay that's what
you want to do right they have in game
live betting the most rewarding player
person to business and see you fantasy
football guys out there fantasy football
guys here you go
you can even bet the over and under and
how many fantasy points and play will
score each game how can you beat that
you can so do me a favor
join today right now my bookie will
match your deposit dollar-for-dollar
again my bookie will match your deposit
dollar-for-dollar use promo code Church
CH you are CH to activate this offer
visit my bookie online today
that's my bookie and I know my Bo ji ie
and don't forget to use promo code
Church when you're creating your account
to claim up to a thousand dollars in
free play again my bookie you play you
win you get [ __ ] paid Lane and
parlayed [ __ ]
number two you want another great
product you got to go in on it when
you're going for supplements kettle
bells all that stuff it's [ __ ]
on ok why you're saying Joey why are we
going on it because one of the company
gives you a [ __ ] money-back
guarantee and they don't want the
product back nobody gives you that you
got a bad piece you got a bad that gag
roller Chinese restaurant
you think they're gonna [ __ ] give me
the money back without a bite missing
from the egg row
they [ __ ] cover that up itself to
somebody else it's just the way it works
you really do they grow that's short
that's gonna somebody been down the lane
and they just read open up and listen to
[ __ ] uncircumcised dick anyway going
on it right on it calm right now press
in church and get 10% off deliver it
right to your [ __ ] house
Ellenor I love you I hope you do great
things no fear thank you for sticking
with it thank you for being a man thank
you thank you show me everything I
didn't teach you dick yeah I was selfish
[ __ ] that egg roll taught me everything
this egg rolls wrong you know I'm saying
the human egg rolls is savage got a bite
out of it you gotta do something I'll
see you [ __ ] Wednesday morning
ready to rock tick-tock we got a couple
of [ __ ] periscopes I'll keep your
[ __ ] poster I love you guys have a
great [ __ ] Monday have a great week
we'll check in with you again
stay black check that [ __ ] mealy